هذه بلده السبوفيتشي في بيلاروسيا التي
تضم منشات عسكريه وساحات تدريب ومخازن
ذخيره
تبعد القاعده قرابه 130 كيلومترا عن منسك
تظهر الصور اقمار اصطناعيه اعمال انشاء
تجري في القاعده العسكريه المهجوره
تتزامن هذه الصور مع تاكيدات بانتقال
مقاتل فاغنر الى الدوله الحليفه لروسيا
وفق وساطه الرئيس لوكاتشينكو بعد تمرد
قائدها
تضمن الاتفاق الذي اوقف تحرك فاجنر داخل
روسيا بندا اكده الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين سيعرض على مقاتلي المجموعه توقيع
عقود مع وزاره الدفاع لينضموا للحرس
الوطني
والحرس الوطني انشا عام 2016
ويعتبر من القوات شبه العسكريه التابعه
للدوله ومن مهامه المشاركه في حمايه
النظام العام وحمايه مرافق الدوله المهمه
والمشاركه في الدفاع عن اراضي الاتحاد
الروسي
لكن قائد المجموعه اتخذ قرارا مخالفا
مقاتلون فاجنر لا ينضموا لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه وهنا يبرز التساؤل لصالح من واين
ستبقى فاجنر تقاتل تتهم فاجنر بارسال
مسلحها الى دول عربيه واخرى في امريكا
اللاتينيه وافريقيا ففي سوريا نشاطات لدعم
قوات النظام السوري منذ عام 2016
خصوصا حول حقول النفط في دير الزور وفي
ليبيا دعمت قوات اللواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر وفي السودان تعمل منذ خمس سنوات تحت
غطاء شركات للتنقيب عن الذهب كما انتشرت
في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى مع ورود تقارير
عن وجود لها في مدغشقر وموزمبيق لتنتشر في
مالي بعد انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه
الخارجيه الروسيه قالت ان على زعماء الدول
الافريقيه اي يقرروا بانفسهم ما اذا كانوا
يريدون مواصله العمل مع مجموعه فاكنر وقال
متحدث الرئاسه الروسيه ان الدوله الروسيه
لا علاقه لها بنشاط المجموعه هناك بينما
نقلت صحيفه وولد الامريكيه ان موسكو ابلغت
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد ان فاجنر في
سوريا لن تعمل بشكل مستقل مضيفه ان مقاتلي
فاجنر انتقلوا بالفعل الى القاعده الروسيه
في اللاذقيه
وبهذا تتحول المجموعه التي وصفت مرات
بذراع الضريبه لروسيا في الخارج الى
مجموعه مسلحه لا يمكن تقدير اعدادها بدقه
غامضه من حيث مصادر التمويل ومناطق العمل
والغطاء السياسي ليبقى الاخطر ربما ما هو
هيكل القياده التي ستعمل وفقه وهل سيكون
الحرس الوطني
بديلا لها
[موسيقى]